Speaker 1: Well, it happened yesterday just
after we were done filming our Thursday show,
Judge Tunji Brown Jackson has been confirmed by
the Senate 53 to 47. She will be the first black
woman on the Supreme Court. It is a major deal
and I'm not going to spend a lot of time on it
today because we've basically spent the time
already. We've talked about her background.
We've talked about her qualifications. We've
talked about some of the most disgusting
confirmation hearings that we've seen. We've
talked about Republicans saying they're not
going to vote for her without really being able
to explain why they're not going to vote for her.
We've talked about all of it and now she's been
confirmed, and indeed it was a 53 to 47 vote.
It was the 48 Democrats, the two independents
that caucus with Democrats and the three
Republicans that we knew were going to support
her because they said so. And that was Senator
Mitt Romney of Utah, Senator Lisa Murkowski
of Alaska and Senator Susan Collins of Maine.
No other Republican supporting one of, if not the
most qualified Supreme Court nominees in. As long
as I've been covering Supreme Court confirmation
hearings and when compared to the nine justices
on the court up until now, as qualified as any of
them. So congratulations to her. We knew she'd be
confirmed and now the next battle is going to
be. What happens if Joe Biden gets another pick
after the midterms and Republicans have taken
control of the Senate? Mitch McConnell was asked
sometime in the last 24 hours if you guys take
the Senate in November. And Joe Biden gets
another pick. Would you even hold confirmation
hearings and Mitch McConnell declined to answer.
And it's the same Partizan nonsense we've been
talking about for a long time. So that's it for
now. The right decision made Judge Jackson will
soon be Justice Jackson on the court. This is
also a bit of good news. The Department of Justice
is finally going to start a formal investigation
into Donald Trump's 15 boxes of records that
he had secreted away at Mar a Lago before they
were turned over to the National Archives, The
Washington Post reporting the Justice Department
has begun taking steps to launch an investigation
into former President Donald Trump's improper
removal of presidential records to Mar a Lago,
some of which were labeled top secret. Remember,
we couldn't vote for Hillary, or we shouldn't
because she couldn't be trusted with secret
information. Trump's flushing documents,
incinerating documents, eating documents,
hiding, hiding away documents at Mar a Lago.
The people who spoke on the condition of
anonymity to discuss an ongoing investigation
said the probe remained in the early stages.
It's not yet clear if the Justice Department
officials have started reviewing the materials
in the boxes, or if they are seeking to interview
those who might have seen them or been involved
in assembling and moving them. The news comes
as the department faces increasing political
pressure to disclose its plans. On Thursday, House
Oversight Chairwoman Carolyn Maloney, Democrat
from New York, accused the Justice Department
of obstructing her committee's investigation
into the 15 boxes of records that Trump took
with him. So, number one, it's about time.
Number two, this is nothing other than step like
zero point one, but at least it's something and
we'll see if and where it goes anywhere. And then
again, I mean, we I gave you some of these numbers
during previous investigations into Trump with
Watergate. It was 783 days from the break in to
Nixon's resignation. And even then, it was only
that quick because Nixon resigned. Here we have
a situation where Trump is no longer
president and we are only in the early stages.
It could be a very, very long time. Iran-Contra,
from Reagan announcing the investigation to
the end of the congressional investigation
was two hundred and fifty four days. These things
do take a long time. I don't have high hopes. I
don't believe Trump is going to do a day in
prison. You guys already know. I think that.
But it does look that, you know, even in the best
cases where something provably wrong was done,
it still takes a really long time. Merrick Garland
got to get his act together. And as a reminder,
Joe Biden should have nothing to do with this
and he's not getting involved. That's the correct
thing, as we spoke about yesterday. Joe Biden
should do nothing to encourage or interfere
with an investigation into Hunter Biden. Joe Biden
should do nothing to interfere with or encourage
an investigation into anything that Donald Trump
has done. But the Justice Department is starting,
and that's good news, and it will likely
mean more legal fees for Donald Trump.
I want to talk about a ridiculous performance
by Pennsylvania Republican Senate candidate
Mehmet Oz, and this is the guy many know it as
Dr. Oz. We are doing everything we can to just
refer to him as Mehmet Oz. Because saying Dr. Oz,
almost, it's like it's useful to him in some way.
Oz is running in Pennsylvania. As I mentioned,
the leading Democratic primary opponent is a guy
named John Fetterman, who we're going to try to
get on the show. Very interesting candidate. And
Mehmet Oz apparently wanted to make the point
that groceries are expensive. This is part of
the inflation story that Republicans have been
telling, but Republicans don't want to tell the
story in good faith. There's been inflation. Gas
prices are high, but it's not Joe Biden's fault.
This is happening globally, but Republicans want
to tell the story that it is Joe Biden's fault. So
what Mehmet Oz did is make a very performative
trip to a local grocery store. And his
point at the grocery store is, look how
expensive it is to buy some vegetables.
This is actually an opportunity for Mehmet Oz
to do something useful at the grocery store,
but he doesn't, and I'm going to explain that in
a second. Let's first take a look at the video
Speaker 2: of grocery shopping and awareness. And
my wife wants some vegetables for crudity, right?
So here's a broccoli that's two bucks, not a ton
of broccoli there. Some asparagus that's four
dollars carrots. That's four more doctors, $10 of
vegetables there. And then we need some guacamole.
That's $4 more. And she loves salsa. Yeah, salsa
there. Six dollars must be a shortage of salsa.
Guys, let's take. And this doesn't
include the tequila. I mean, it's
outrageous. And we got Joe Biden the thankless.
Speaker 1: OK. So he he makes a show. By the way,
do we believe he's really there shopping? I
don't. He makes a show of picking up a $2 piece
of broccoli and a $4 asparagus and a $4. It's an
enormous bag of carrots for Ford. I think it's a
five pound bag. $4. Guacamole. $6 salsa. So it's
$20 for his crudity. Ingredients. So, first of
all, salsa for crudity. No, that's the first
red flag here. That makes absolutely no sense.
Why are you getting salsa for crudity? But
that's a culinary critique, but it exposes
that this is probably all B.S.. But secondly, it's
obviously super staged to make a political point.
He's not out really shopping for crew to take
to make for his guests. It's absurd. It's like
when Mitt Romney went out to shop and all he
had in his cart was just boxes and boxes of
yogurt. And I think, like seltzer, it was really
weird. It wasn't believable. It was during his
presidential campaign. But this is really a missed
opportunity. Instead of complaining about prices
and buying things that don't even make
sense for the dish you claim to be making
as a doctor, and here's where it is relevant that
he's a medical doctor, he should be explaining to
people how to more economically buy vegetables,
which most Americans aren't getting enough of
buying too many processed foods. Now he's a doctor
who's promoted quack cures on his show called
Cures for Colds that are completely unproven, all
sorts of weird supplements and different things.
And then when he actually has an opportunity
to talk people in a real way about nutrition,
he talks about inflation and tries to blame Joe
Biden. He could have gone and said, Hey, you know
what? Instead of processed foods, here's how you
can get real foods cheaply and make them last.
This would be value if any member of a member of
Congress Congress did this Republican or Democrat,
I would applaud them. This is a big problem in the
United States. People don't know what's healthy.
They don't understand how to economically have
healthier foods. Food products highly processed
are promoted to them. He could go in and go
see this monstrous five pound bag of carrots.
It's four bucks, and that's a good deal. Cut up
some of the carrots. Get hummus for three bucks.
That's a great snack. Take some carrots
and grate them onto your salads to get
more. Whatever. I don't remember, I'm not a
doctor. Is it vitamin A? Whatever carrots have
beta carotene? Take some carrots. Put a little
avocado or olive oil or even canola oil on them
salt and pepper. Roast them. Now you've got great
sides for your lunches instead of potato chips
for the entire week. That's a great
use of a five pound bag of carrots.
Instead, it's a confused guy claiming to be
making crudity with salsa. Hey, let me tell
you about vegetables that are the best value in
the grocery store. We should all be doing more to
eat healthy. Get yourself sweet potatoes. Get the
bulk bag. Roast them alongside your carrots. Keep
them as a side dish for breakfast. Get some eggs.
Toss some cubed up. Already cooked sweet potato.
Fry an egg and then have a handful of
blueberries or whatever the case may be.
These are ideas to buy in larger quantities,
don't have food waste and eat healthier than
a highly processed whatever it is. You know, the
granola bars or whatever it is you're having for,
you know, sugary cereal, whatever. It's
really a wasted opportunity for a doctor
to really provide something of value and show
that he's the type of voice we should be saying.
We need more of that in the Senate. We need. This
is exactly what we need more of in the Senate.
He does something cheap. It adds nothing to the
conversation other than playing the same political
games. That's Mehmet Oz running in Pennsylvania.
Let me know your thoughts. Find me on Twitter
at de Packman. We'll take a quick break. What
a Friday program we have for you today. The
David Pakman Show is, of course, made possible by
viewers like you through our membership program,
listeners like you. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com. It's quick, it's easy
if you already have a membership. You can also
now gift memberships by checking the box that says
this is a gift. Funny enough, as you
sign up and then we will give your gift
subscription to someone on our waiting list.
Currently, 600 people waiting for membership,
so it's a beautiful number. Let's hear from some
people in the audience. We do these calls now via
Discord. You can find our discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Why don't we start today?
This is interesting. Let's start with Alicia
from the Pharoh Islands. We've never had a
Pharaoh Islands caller before. Aliya, you're
on the air. What's going on? No, boy. Aliya,
don't let us down. Aliya from the Faroe
Islands, please unmute and will be able to chat.
Well, that's a shame. That would have been
interesting. Let's go instead to Brian from
Phenix, Brian from Phenix. You're on the air.
Hi, David. Hey, how are you?
Speaker 2: I am doing amazing. I wanted
to first appreciate you flouting the pushback
and sticking with the an historic pronunciation.
I think it's Oh boy, I appreciate you're going
going your own way on that. All right, fair.
I'm wondering if you believe in the long
term, it would be a more beneficial,
more progressive outcome to remove the filibuster
altogether and sort of have the Senate answer
to the voters for whatever legislation is able
to be passed in a in a 50 50 Senate? Or if you
think that that would lead us in the opposite
direction in a in a less progressive direction.
Speaker 1: Good question. So I here's my view on
this. If I don't think about this strategically,
the filibuster doesn't make a lot of sense
to me. The filibuster fundamentally seems
anti-democratic, so if there were no political
considerations, I would say let's get rid of
the filibuster altogether. In practical terms,
I'm aware that if Democrats completely nuke the
filibuster, at some point it'll come back to haunt
Democrats. And part of the reason why is that the
Senate is fundamentally anti-democratic. And what
I mean by that is we have 100 senators, no matter
how many people live in any particular state.
That's the state has two senators. And so there
are senators that represent millions and millions
and millions of people and their senators that
represent, I mean, I don't know what the Wyoming
population is now. I think it's like 700000. So
like each Wyoming senator in a sense, represents
350000 people, which gives disproportionate power
to low population states, which are typically
conservative. So I don't love the filibuster.
I think it doesn't make sense, and I would be
fine getting rid of it if we were to somehow fix
the anti-democratic nature of the Senate, which
doesn't seem like it's going to happen anytime
soon, because that's the way the system works.
Speaker 2: One semi follow up question very quick,
would you support adding states
for that in the form of like
splitting California or adding Puerto Rico?
Speaker 1: I am open to adding states, but it
would not be specifically for that reason. I think
that sometimes it would make sense. There's a lot
of people. I mean, I think Puerto Rico should
be a state if it wants to be. I think there are
a number of different arguments for splitting
up California, but for me, it's more about does
it make sense for economic reasons as it makes
sense for other reasons, not just as a political
strategy, although as a political strategy,
it would almost certainly help Democrats.
Awesome, thanks, David. My pleasure. That's
a that's a meaty phone call, I like it.
Let's go next to Austin from Miami,
Austin from Miami. You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi. I was just kind of wondering
what you think about what's going to happen
in midterm elections? I mean, I'm not looking too
much at like polls at this point, but just from my
perception, I feel like Democrats are getting a
lot less popular. A lot of people, you know, are
blaming Biden for the gas bill or the gas prices.
And I just feel like if they don't do anything
about it, they're going to stay very unpopular. I
was wondering if you thought that they were either
aware of it or like what you would recommend.
Speaker 1: So I think Democrats are aware
of it. So so there's two sides to
this. Austin, the first part of it is
historically, and if you can do something to
turn off the discord blinks, that would be
really great. I don't know if you're using push to
talk or if you haven't silence notifications, but
I would love your help with that. So on the one
hand, for historical reasons, typically when a
party wins the White House, then the next midterms
aren't good for them. So like historically
speaking, Democrats should should lose at least
control of the House or Senate in November.
On the other hand, we have this situation where
in 2016 and 2020 you had a lot of Trumpists
voting who never voted before Trump. They only
got involved in politics because of Trump. And
it remains an open question whether there is going
to be a sort of a disappearance of many of those
individuals, and they're not even going to vote
in November. The other question is we know COVID
has killed more Republicans than Democrats. To
what effect will the Partizan death gap of COVID
affect Republicans, so Democrats should be losing?
Historically, Joe Biden is also getting blamed
for stuff that's not his fault, like gas prices.
That's that those are not good things for them.
But I think it's such a unique midterm that
it remains to be seen. I don't really have
a prediction.
Speaker 3:
Yeah. Do you think that though, like certain parts
like, I don't know, do you think, do you see kind
of the new like decriminalization of marijuana
bill is like something that they might be
putting forth to kind of reclaim some popularity
because I just feel like from the perspective,
like they have not really gotten anything done
with like the infrastructure bill being gutted
and they're not really doing anything popular
like as of right now or making an effort to.
Speaker 1: I think that time is quite short
and it would be really great for Democrats if
they want to do well to try to get something
else major done. But to be perfectly frank,
it's not seeming to me like they're they're going
to be able to do it. So they're going to have to
run on convincing people based on what's already
happened. And that's quite frankly, it seems like
that's going to be a difficult thing to do.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I kind of just wish they
had more control over, you know, getting policies
that are popular, but obviously there's a lot of,
I guess, red tape within the party.
Speaker 1: Yeah, and there's also a
limited amount of political capital. The
one thing I will say is I don't really
think Joe Biden has much of an interest
in doing student loan forgiveness, but
he still could look at doing something like that.
And maybe the new moratorium on payments until
August is him saying, Well, maybe in August,
I'll do some student loan forgiveness, which
will help us in November. That was Pat's idea on
a recent bonus show. I don't know. I don't know,
but I think it's an interesting question.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Well, thank you for your time,
I definitely agree that Biden should be doing
some kind of like emergency kind of catch up.
I feel like you're just catching a lot of flak
for inflation and gas. And like, I obviously
don't have like any like concrete evidence on
this. But just from what I've seen living in,
like Florida, I'm at the University of Florida,
but I'm from Miami. Just a lot of like A. Biden
sentiment. Let's go, Brandon is everywhere.
Yeah. I'm just a little worried for the future.
Speaker 1: You're right to be worried. Austin,
thank you so much for the call. Let's go next
to Jamie from Georgia. Jamie, welcome.
Speaker 2: Hi, thank you for welcoming
me. My pleasure. Yes. So, David, what I wanted
to touch on and I wanted to talk today about
was there was the rise of socialism in the
US, according to this Axios poll. Apparently,
it's like forty nine to 46 percent split between
favorably viewing socialism and capitalism. I
don't know which way it is, but either way,
what are what are your thoughts on the rise?
Speaker 1: I have to tell you, I don't know what
you're talking about, so you're seeing the rise
of socialism as popularity. Are you saying?
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Like,
I'm sorry, I didn't. I don't think I explained
this very well. I mean, like the rise between
the rise of socialism being viewed in a more
favorable light compared to capitalism being
viewed in a very positive light. For instance,
during the Red Scare in the US, socialism was
very negatively compared to capitalism.
Speaker 1: OK, I don't have the numbers in
front of me, but I know that you're correct that
socialism is seen less unfavorably in the U.S. now
than it has been in a long time. So let's agree
that that's going on and the specific numbers
maybe, maybe we don't have in front of us. I
don't have any particular hot take on that.
I mean, listen, here's what's going on.
The version of capitalism that exists
in the United States has failed many, many
millions of people. When we look at wages,
when we look at access to just basics that people
need to live, we have hunger in the United States,
there is no reason for that, et cetera, et
cetera. It's natural that people would say,
Wow, this isn't working, what else is there? And
one of the other things that there is in theory is
socialism. So it's not shocking to me, given the
version of capitalism that exists here, that there
would be people looking for other things. As far
as socialism goes, I'm not personally a socialist
that doesn't mean anything in particular. But
my point is I'm not like looking to usher in
socialism and socializing the means of production
and socialized ownership of businesses. I'm
not looking to do that. I think a lot of the
people that now view socialism more favorably
also aren't looking to do that, and they don't
actually know what socialism is. So that's sort
of my take. Not surprising. People are looking
for alternatives. A lot of them don't really
know what socialism is. A lot of the people that
claim to be socialists aren't really like Bernie
says he's a democratic socialist. Maybe he is. But
his policy is one of social democracy, which is a
regulated capitalism. So I think there's some
confusion and there's some logic to it as well.
Speaker 2: Yes, I think that's a very good
take, man. Thank you. Yeah, I I will I will say
yes, the the U.S. in the US, what is considered
socialism has largely been incredibly stunted,
of course, due to the red scares and uber
reactionary ism that's fostered in the US culture.
But what I think that a good way to combat this
would be to educate would be to educate people
on what socialism really is. Sure. And yeah, and I
think, you know, and I would and I would classify
personally, I would classify social democracy as
not a form of socialism, but as sort of like a
sort of like a window into socialism.
When people see that this little nugget
of socialism, something that's barely even
socialism, not even the economic policies,
but just the everything else policies of social
democracy. Yeah, I think that people will be like,
Hey, so this is just a nugget of socialism.
This is really good if we have this, but on a
much larger scale and in a way that we make sure
does not end up like the Soviet Union or China,
then we can have socialism. And I think
that socialism will have even more of a
boom than it already has experience.
Speaker 1: So I don't agree with you
personally. I think that having social
democracy would lead us towards being
like the northern European countries, which are
still capitalist countries. But what I will say,
what you just said is the view of a lot of
incrementalist socialists. So for example,
there's a streamer named Ian Walsh, and when I
spoke to Ian Walsh, he said, I'm a socialist,
but if we're ever going to have socialism,
it's going to go through social democracy
so that people realize, Hey, this is the right
direction to go in. So the view you're espousing,
while it's not one I agree with, is a valid
and widely held view among actual socialists,
and I appreciate you making that point.
Speaker 2: Mm-Hmm. Thank you. My pleasure. It's
about all I had. So thank you for calling
me, David. See you. See you next time.
Speaker 1: All right. We will see
you next time. Appreciate the call.
Let's go next to why don't we go from Donny
from is it pronounced? Visalia, Visalia?
It's Visalia. Visalia, what state is that in?
Patents in California. Oh, beautiful. Before I
did, I also not know where it
was the last time we spoke.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I probably should take
it to the very carrier also mentioned that
they do on Trump mentioning the 17th or 1917
pandemic being connected to Q&A, and that's
what I called last time.
Speaker 1: Beautiful,
but what's on your mind today, anyway?
Speaker 2: I was wondering what you
what your opinion was of Adam Schiff? As
for president, like, I'm not sure if his
policies are really progressive or not, but
I'm curious if he's and if you think he'd
have any interest, how do you think he would do?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Adam Schiff, I find to be an
interesting guy, a very smart, great speaker. Not
the most progressive guy on the face of the Earth.
And he will bump up against anti-Semitism as a
Jewish gentleman. I think that if I were to look
in that direction, I'd be more interested in Jamie
Raskin than Adam Schiff. I think Jamie Raskin is
really a progressive activist. And so if you said
Schiff or Raskin in thinking about the kind of
like, you know, a Jewish Jewish white guy with
that sort of profile, I think I would lean more
Raskin than Schiff.
Speaker 2:
Yeah. Okay, great. Well, that's all I had.
Speaker 1: All right. Beautiful, short and sweet.
I appreciate the call. Let's see. Let's go next
to let's go to snug Wrangler. And the thing about
snug Wrangler is Snug Wrangler is a professional
member, but nugs phone calls are not at the same
caliber as the Mims, but what's going on snug?
Speaker 2: Oh, David. Oh, mom, no.
Speaker 1: OK.
Speaker 4: So I was reading a
piece over at the American Prospect, a progressive
news magazine, and there was a piece there talking
about profit rates should be included in economic
data, not just wages, unemployment rate, prices,
etc.. What do you think about this and how
do you see things changing if profits were
actually studied and included in economic data?
Speaker 1: Oh, aren't they in a way in so let
me see if I can think that through? So you're
saying, OK, we have a lot of different ways
of measuring how an economy is doing.
We can look at the unemployment rate,
we can look at wages, we can look at GDP, we
can look at inflation, consumer confidence.
You're saying let's include corporate
profits in that list of metrics.
Speaker 4: Yeah, you know, that way we could gauge
maybe if there's a profit gouging stuff like that.
The piece I was reading was also talking
about how it's not really studied. So it's
it's hard to, I guess, use that as a
measurement, even if it should be somehow.
Speaker 1: I am always into having
more information rather than less. I
think you're onto something which is there.
What are we? It's a hard thing to calculate
in the sense that are we talking about the average
profit margin? Are we talking about dollars?
Is it weighted based on company size? I
think if I knew a little more about what
exactly would be measured, I could give you a
more definite opinion about it. But I'm always
for having more information rather than less.
Speaker 4: Yeah, all those things mentioned,
you know, could be possible, definitely
is an area of study that should be looked
into. I agree with you should also be
some kind of measurement of how many,
how many times people are using their toilet.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, if it's if you have a
president, OK, you're playing clips. Yeah. Listen,
if you have a regime where people are flushing 10
to 15 times, that can't possibly be as good as if
people are only flushing once. I agree with you.
OK, thank you. Thank you. All right, Doug
Wrangler with a better phone call than normal,
I like it coming in with the with the
SoundClips. Very, very good. OK. Let's
go next to Jess in Oregon. Jess, welcome.
Speaker 5: Hello, David, how are you? So
I'm just I'm just doing so wonderful, I we call,
I'm sorry, I called a few weeks ago from Florida,
from Gainesville, Florida, right? And
I've made my move. So now I'm here now.
Speaker 1: Are you in Oregon or Oregon?
Speaker 5: I have not I have been here about three
weeks and not heard one person call it Oregon,
Speaker 1: so you can't say for sure,
but it sounds like you're in Oregon.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think I think that's
where Eugene is, as in Oregon.
Yeah, beautiful, beautiful. So
I was wondering, I would love to get your take
on if this is a good potential middle ground
to pro-life and pro pro-abortion rights.
Speaker 1: So we there's have you ever met a
pro-abortion person? I never have pro-abortion to
means you're going around trying to get people to
have abortions. I've never seen that right.
Speaker 5: I said, OK, I should.
I should. I should.
Speaker 1: Pro-Choice,
pro-choice, abortion rights.
Speaker 5: OK, particularly. OK, got it. So
if we're going, if we're talking about people who
are for abortion rights and people on the other
side who think that that is murdering babies, you
know, it's kind of hard to find a middle ground.
But see, I'm thinking of it like. Why do we keep
talking about that particular aspect of abortion
when there are a lot of other aspects around this
that I think we can agree on, like young mothers
who, you know, maybe would rather have
abortion if they can't get abortion, then
you know, I'd add, like federal funding
for young mothers to these bills,
to these bills that that restrict abortion rights.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. Yeah. One of the things
we've talked about many times is you can't both
say you should be forced to have a kid and then
not provide any support for
the kid to people who are not
financially in a good position to have a kid.
Speaker 5: Absolutely right. Because, yeah,
you know, if the if the other solution
is get rid of the kid before it's born
and you can't do that, OK, well, then help me
out if I'm forced to have a kid, you know?
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is the broader. This
is the broader hypocrisy of an insane amount of
concern for, you know, clumps of cells for weeks
into a pregnancy and then total disregard
for babies after they're born. I mean that
that's a long term hypocrisy we've seen.
Speaker 5: But see, instead of like I know you
and I and many other people who share that
same view, we kind of get stuck on like,
Oh, you pro-life people are being so hypocritical
instead of be like pro-life people. What
about this idea? Do you agree with this?
Speaker 1: Sure. No, it should be proposed.
Absolutely. The problem is most in most cases,
if Democrats try to bring that up during a debate
over abortion. Republicans would say that's not
this bill. If you want to propose a different
bill, propose it. But right now we're talking
about this bill so that that's the political
strategy question you have to deal with.
Speaker 5: Really? Yeah. So I think that
that's a different situation really well.
Speaker 1: They would say it's not part of
Republicans would say that's just not part of
our bill. If you want to propose that propose it,
but you've got to make your own bill.
Speaker 5: Aha! Because
because restricting abortion isn't a
direct cause to that effect. Oh, of
Speaker 1: course you're right about
you're not wrong that it's of course
related. OK. All right. Just thank you for
the call. I appreciate it. What I'm saying is
the Republicans wouldn't allow it into their
bill. They would say, Here's what we want to
do about abortion. Here's what's right to do about
abortion. If you have other ideas that you want to
propose, by all means, go ahead and propose them.
Let's take a very quick break. If you're holding,
just keep holding because we're going
right back to the phones in a moment.
Let's go back to the phones and by phones,
I mean, discord, it's not really phones, but
for some reason we keep calling them phones.
I guess they are calls their discord calls
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go,
where are we going to go next? Because it's
just it's crazy what's happening on the
Discord lines today? Let's try Alex from
Spokane or Spokane, Washington. You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David, how are you doing? I'm doing
well. So I wanted to touch on this topic, given
the Democratic leadership you had Steny Hoyer
and Jim Clyburn. And there tends to be this
conventional wisdom that progressive Democrats
can only win in districts like a on a Pressley's,
and that if we were to turn the Democratic Party
toward a more progressive direction that we
would, that we would lose nationwide. And
there is a piece on Jacobin about this, given
the fact that rural voters have really turned
toward the Republican Party. And the reality
is that in 2022, I have seen a candidate that
has run a totally grassroots, people powered
congressional bid. And that's Derrick Marshall.
He's running in the 23rd Congressional District,
down in the high desert of Southern California.
And I was just curious if you've been keeping
tabs on the midterms and if there's any.
That had, like struck your eye as candidates
running in rural areas, places that are maybe
unconventional so that we can continue to fight
for issues that are affecting people who are maybe
most disproportionately affected by
poverty and by the day to day struggle.
Speaker 1: I can't say specifically that there's
progressive rural candidates that I would be able
to sort of like recommend to anybody. But my
recommendation would be if you are in a rural
area, find out who's running because my capacity
on the show to know about every candidate running
everywhere is is very limited in my ability to
interview all of them is also very limited. But
we're going to have very soon. I was interviewed
by Farron Cousins in Las Vegas recently, and he's
going to be publishing an interview. We did sort
of about exactly this issue, which is how do you
deal with figuring out what races to get involved
in? And I'm going to be talking about it on the
show as well. But but you know, and unfortunately,
it's beyond the scope of my show to tell everybody
who to support, et cetera, et cetera. But there's
no shortage of great candidates out there, and
it's great that you're paying attention.
Speaker 2: I'm thinking,
Speaker 1: all right there. There we go. Very,
very important message for sure. Let's go
next. Where where are we going next here?
What about I don't know? How about Billy
from Jersey? Billy, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine, Billy.
Speaker 2: OK, quick question,
please. Can you describe to me what a woman
is giving? Actually, my question is when you
think of somebody who is radical and behavior.
It's somebody who may be erratic. How would you
describe a radical type of a person?
Speaker 1: Is it an erratic radical?
Speaker 2: I. Decisions they make and things
they do, because at a Trump rally come out,
the former president will say a radical
do nothing Democrats in the same sentence,
right? Which means they're all over the place,
but they're also doing completely nothing.
Speaker 1: Billy, there's a crazy squealing in the
background, and it sounds like you got a TV on.
And it sounds like you're on speaker. Is there,
can you? Can you help us out here? So we're on the
same team rather than on opposite teams?
Speaker 2: So sorry.
With See?
Speaker 1:
So, Billy, tell me, is this like a word game or
a political question I'm trying to figure out,
are we just playing games with
the words erratic and radical or
what's going on?
Speaker 2: Oh.
Just. It's when you call
somebody a radical. Oh boy.
Speaker 1: All right, Billy, I'm going to let
you go, Wow, it's crazy what's happening over
at Billy's place. It's it's really it's quite a
scene. It's hard to even keep up with all of it.
Let's go to Mike in northeastern
Connecticut. Mike, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: David, thank you for taking my call. I
had a question about ranked choice voting, OK, why
Massachusetts didn't pass that in the last vote.
Speaker 1: Did that not pass in Massachusetts,
I don't remember there are so many ballot
initiatives, I can't remember all of them. I
don't know why it didn't pass, if that's
the case, but I've spoken about ranked
choice voting a number of times. There's a
number of different configurations of it,
single transferable vote and many others.
I think the most important thing when it
comes to ranked choice voting is voters need
to be confident that there is no possible way
that someone who really doesn't have a plurality
of voters wanting them to be the winner
ends up as the winner. And it's sort of like a
mathematical problem, and we've done a number of
interviews on this. There's a number of systems
that ensure that and that accomplish that.
And it's generally speaking a system I'm in favor
of with the caveat that I would like to see ranked
choice voting and public financing of elections
and campaign finance reform because not only
is it important to generate votes for
third parties and additional parties,
it would also be great for the main two parties
not to have such an overwhelming advantage when
it comes to the money. So I think you need
to do both together. I'd also love to see a
national popular vote, and all of these things
together feel like pipe dreams, but they're
the ideal that that I've sort of envisioned.
Speaker 2: Now, do you feel the voters would be
competent enough to fill more a regular ballot?
Speaker 1: I don't know. I mean, we do have a
competence and education problem in the United
States. I'm pretty confident that if people
just get a piece of paper and it says there
are five candidates, rank them one to five
that most voters would be able to do that
correctly. I'm modestly confident in that.
Speaker 2: OK, great. And do you ever touch
on the right to repair that was another
Massachusetts ballot initiative?
Speaker 1: I'm generally speaking
in favor of the right to repair. I've
heard the arguments that right to repair
would allow people to get vehicles fixed or
devices fixed by people who aren't really
qualified. But I don't really buy that. I
think you can deal with the qualification
in the certification. So my view is
it's basically a way to monopolize of
service and repair dollars, and I'm in favor
of right to repair. Great. Thank you for taking
my call. My pleasure, Mike, from northeastern
Connecticut. A lot of interesting stuff there.
Let's go next to Jude from Baltimore. Hey Jude.
Speaker 2: Hey, what's going on, David? So today
I have a question, I have two questions, if that's
all right. Sure. So my first question is actually,
you know, you mentioned that we could be losing
the House and or the Senate in these midterm
elections coming up. So what is the best piece
of legislation or the best thing we could see
before we possibly lose power in November?
Speaker 1: So there's two different questions
here. There is what would be the most impactful to
the country and what might get Democrats the most
votes on the ladder. I continue to think that some
students significant student loan forgiveness. And
remember, Joe Biden can't just forgive all student
loans. The best legal opinions I've read are that
that that would need to go through Congress.
That's my understanding. But but significant
student loan forgiveness, I think, would get a lot
of votes for Democrats in November. When, when,
if you're asking me, what do I think is the one
thing that would be most impactful to the country?
It's the typical big issues everybody talks about
wholesale campaign finance reform, health care
for all serious climate change regulations and
legislation, but those are not necessarily the
things that would be most popular with voters.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree, I think that a lot
of people, what they see, they they think
of maybe one or two issues that they're
really passionate about and they don't take into
account the entire like focus of things. So I'm a
student myself. I go to the University
of Maryland, Baltimore County. OK. Yes,
I'm a I'm an environmental engineering major
like chemical engineering environmental track,
so I care about climate change. But that doesn't
stop me from, you know, thinking about other
issues that are also important. And I think a
lot of people got to do that. Would you agree?
Absolutely, yeah. And then my second question
is, do we still care about vaccine hesitancy?
Is it still a very big problem because we're
getting to the point now where it's been
20? What is it? Twenty five months since COVID
first really hit? Yeah. And you know, we still
have, you know, I don't know the statistics, but
at least a quarter of, you know, African-Americans
or black people not wanting to take the vaccine.
And at least I don't know some, maybe 20 or
somewhere in the teens for white people. So
are we still concerned about those people not
getting the vaccine or are they still hurting us?
Yeah. Are we so far away from it that it's like,
why is it's not even that big an issue anymore?
Speaker 1: I don't know the numbers that you just
stated, but there's a ton of people that still
refuse to get vaccinated. Here's my thought
on that. At this stage of the pandemic, the
vaccination becomes increasingly an individual
decision. There's still some data that the degree
to which unvaccinated people spread the disease
is higher, but it's not like the be all end
all where we say, Oh, if you're vaccinated,
you don't spread it. If you're vaccinated, you
get much less seriously ill. So we're a little
less concerned about the vaccine refusers for that
reason. The problem is the vast majority of the
vaccine refusal is based on incorrect beliefs
and usually when people are vaccine refusers,
they also believe a lot of other crazy stuff. So
we care about it because it's part of this kind of
culture of ignorance and people who don't
accept science and that type of thing.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree, it's like that, it's
like that part of like ideology where people
think that, you know, grass is blue and then
they vote for Donald Trump. Right? You know,
that's when we get people in the White House like
that. That's exactly right. Yeah, exactly. On my
campus. We have to wear a mask only when we're
inside classrooms, but not we're inside buildings
or at the gym. You know, at school places. So it's
interesting to me because I'm thinking, OK, well,
you know, obviously there's still a
problem anyhow. We need to wear a mask,
but we don't really have to wear it. So
what's the point of these rules? And it's
been two years, so it's just kind of jumbling.
Speaker 1: It's not a totally coherent strategy.
I totally totally agree with that. Dude, thank
you so much for the call. I appreciate it.
All right, there's Jude. Oops. Sorry,
Jude was saying one last thing there,
but I cut off Jude. I apologize for that.
Thank you to everyone who called in.
Sorry if I didn't get to you.
We will take calls again.
It's time for the Friday mailbag, let's get
to it, if you have something to say, hopefully
something substantive, hopefully something
relevant to the audience. Hopefully something
related to things that have actually been said
on the show, unlike many of the emails I get.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
Don't abuse it. Don't send too many emails or
you'll get blocked. We'll start today with this
is a little bonus. This one is actually from
Facebook. I'm sorry. This was from YouTube. This
is from Rob Rob, who says David Pakman hates
the God bless the USA. What a loser. Now
this. This could mean one of two things,
and this relates to the I've told you guys
that something about Trump rallies in 2022
is really triggering to the Trumpists. I
would cover Trump rallies in 2017. In 2016,
I would cover Trump rallies leading up to the 2020
election, even in 2021. Those weird Trump rallies,
the Trump is didn't really care about my
coverage. They didn't seem triggered by it
in 2020, too. Every time I cover a Trump rally
live, I get a deluge of YouTube comments, Twitter
replies and emails from people furious with my
coverage. Now, this could mean one of two things
Rob might mean that I hate the USA, which of
course I don't or rob might mean I hate that
terrible country song that Trump plays at every
rally that ends. God bless the USA or starts
that way or is called that I don't even really
know. I don't like the song, so it could mean
one of two things. I don't know which it is,
but I appreciate hearing from Rob as always,
Jeff wrote. To me, this is fascinating. Jeff
is a former Trump supporter, and Jeff wrote to
me and said, Mr. Pacman with great respect. I
voted for Donald Trump twice. I was a moderate
Republican with left social views, and I didn't
realize just how much Q Anon had infiltrated
the party until January 6th. As a result of that,
and I really like Kirsten Cinema and Jared Polis.
I will be voting with the Democrats until this rot
has been removed. I'm worried about Democrats and
independents not voting this fall because they
might be mad about inflation and other issues.
What can I as a betrayed Trump supporter, do to
help get the anti-Trump vote out in 22 and 24?
Phone bank. Phone. Bank, phone. Bank. Phone
Bank. For any candidate that you believe
is a sort of sort of a swing district, an
important seat in 2022. Jeff also said, I figured
out about Trump's demagogery on my own. But your
show has helped me become more comfortable with
the left. Thank you, Jeff. This is a beautiful
email. Great to hear from Jeff about this issue,
and this is, you know, this is a reminder this
stuff matters. People listen to this and we do
have an impact. It is great to hear. Now I know a
lot of you will focus in on, as you can see here,
where Jeff says he likes Kirsten Cinema, and I
know my progressive audience really doesn't like
Kirsten Center. I don't focus on that focus on
the fact that this is someone who voted for Trump
twice, who now is not voting for Republicans.
That's still a good thing. Next e-mail is from Ray
Ray. This one's actually from this one's actually
from YouTube. Ray Ray said David says he doesn't
care about Bible quotations and then quotes
the Bible and gives passage location as a Jew.
David has not followed King David and yielded
his will to Yahweh. He has rejected Messiah
and the propitious Asian offered by Jesus as a
blood sacrifice for sin. He is a child of wrath
and unredeemed, a rebel against Yahweh, and one
of them a lawyer asking him a question, testing
him. Teacher, what is the great commandment in
the law? And he said, You shall love the Lord,
your god with all your heart and with all your
soul and with all your mind. This is the great and
foremost commandment. OK, this is out of control.
Crazy, but the one part I want to address is.
Do people understand that when I say. I don't
care about the Bible, but for people who do.
Here is what it says. That is, I think, clear to
most people, and the context was Madison Cawthorn,
Madison Cawthorn had wrongly quoted the Bible
and what I said was, I don't care what the
Bible says one way or the other. I don't
care. But Madison Cawthorn claims to care
and his followers claim to care. So for the people
that do care? Here is what the Bible actually says
it. You guys understand that, right? That's
not it. That's not a double standard.
Ray Ray, you got to get it together, my
friend Brandon wrote in about accountability.
And Brandon wrote, David, I was wondering,
why are Congress members allowed to lie
without consequence all the time? Is there a
way to hold them accountable for these lies,
such as a policy that makes them come
clean after proven to be wrong? To me,
that just seems like a normal courtesy of everyday
people. Thanks for your thoughts. Yeah, I mean,
listen, brand is not wrong. It would be great if
more elected officials did what I do on the show,
which is when I know I've gotten something wrong,
not buried on the bonus show at the top of the
show, I will say, guys, I got something wrong
yesterday, gals. I have to make a correction.
But anything beyond that actually could
potentially violate the First Amendment.
So I'm not I'm not sure exactly what you have in
mind, Brandon, but as a show of common decency,
it would be great for elected officials not to lie
as much and when they get things wrong to correct
them as quickly as possible. Lauren Rhoden about
trans rights and critical race theory. Lawrence
said, Good evening, David, this question may be
a bit ignorant, and I've tried to read up on it
without a veil. My question is, is trans rights
part of critical race theory or are these two
different issues? I assumed critical race theory
was solely race related. But I hear all of these
people associating them as the same issue. I
appreciate your perspective. Thank you for being a
logical voice in this illogical world. So, Lauren,
let me give you two answers. The first answer is
everything can be related to any fight against
injustice can be related. And to the extent that
supporters of critical race theory and supporters
of trans rights believe that both are frameworks
for giving people rights and beat them up, it all
could be related. So I know that if I just say
these are two different issues, someone will
say David, sir, or they might be less polite,
you're being discriminatory by claiming that
these are unrelated issues. Now, my opinion is
these are unrelated issues. So you can always
find some thread to link things together. You
can link together, you know, Mandarin oranges
and, you know, nuclear energy. I don't know.
I'm sure you could. But but these really are
two separate things. Critical race theory
is a subset of critical theory, critical theory,
a great framework for understanding literature,
a great framework from the mid 20th century for
thinking about a lot of different things and
critical race theory specifically wants to apply
that to our understanding of race and society,
and different people have different opinions on
it. I'm not like big on critical race theory.
Critical theory. I find fascinating postmodernism.
I find fascinating. OK, etc. Fine. So that's
critical. Race theory at trans rights is about
trans rights, and it relates to equality under
the law. It relates to the bathroom stuff. There's
the sports element of it. There's who can sue for
gender discrimination. And that came up during
the Katagiri Brown Jackson hearings. So again,
with the idea that CRT concerns itself with rights
along race and trans rights released the trans
rights, you could say there's some thread there.
But yes, you're not wrong, Lauren, that these
there are two separate issues here. Swift wrote
in about Social Security and Medicare bankruptcy.
So it says Mr Pacman, sir, I've been told many
times by many people that Medicare and Social
Security are going bankrupt on your show today.
You mentioned this is not true. Can you please
elaborate on this? So I understand better, OK?
So there is a difference between going bankrupt
and headed towards insolvency. Bankruptcy is.
That's it. You're out of business. You can't
pay Medicare. Being bankrupt means they can't pay
for anybody's health. Health care, Social Security
being bankrupt means there's no more Social
Security benefits for anybody if nothing is done.
With cost of living, growing and baby boomers
retiring, Social Security could get to the point
where if nothing changes, they wouldn't be
able to pay their full benefits to everybody.
OK, so what does that mean? You have to do? Well,
there's a couple different ways you could do it.
You could reduce benefits. You could make people
wait longer to retire or you could collect more
money. And one of the simplest ways you can
fix Social Security's insolvency that would
eventually come and eventually is you raise the
cap on which Social Security tax is collected
right now. You only pay Social Security tax on
roughly your first hundred and thirty ish thousand
dollars. So if you make $200000 a year that lasts
70 K, you're not paying into Social Security at
all. If you make a million dollars a year, you
that last eight hundred and seventy k, you're
not paying into Social Security. So there's some
really small tweaks that could be made to fix the
insolvency issue. Similarly, with Medicare, with
health care costs rising, baby boomers retiring,
etc. If nothing is changed, Medicare could
become insolvent, which means it would have it
would have a budget crunch, not bankruptcy. Really
important to understand. Not a subtle difference,
Jim wrote in about the Will Smith smack and said,
Do you think the right wing is upset about Will
Smith because they're confusing Chris Rock for Kid
Rock? As as funny as that is, Jim and I have not
heard that before. I actually don't think that's
the confusion, but I love the I love the idea.
Very, very clever. And lastly, Patrick wrote
in, and Patrick says question. Watch your show
sometimes curious. When are you going to discuss
Hunter Biden's laptop? Like to hear your comments?
We will talk about Hunter Biden's laptop
when there's really something to talk about.
There is an investigation into Hunter Biden's
business dealings. They don't relate to the
laptop, and I already covered it. That's really
the story. And Hunter Biden has nothing to do with
the Biden administration, so there's not too much
to say about it. But if there's something to cover
about Hunter Biden's laptop and if Hunter Biden
becomes relevant to what's going on politically?
Joe Biden something something relevant. Be sure
that I will be covering it, my friend. No question
about it. That's going to do it for today. We
have a tremendous bonus show coming up for you.
Become a member. Sign up at join Packman dot com.
And remember, if you already have a membership,
you can now gift memberships to others. Just go
through the signup process, check the box that
says this is a gift. We have 600 people waiting
for memberships who have requested memberships.
Make someone's dream come true. Gift
a membership at Join Passive Income.
I'll see you on the bonus show.